using deep chain we can perform in
silico side directed mutagenesis on a
protein complex where we select the
position we want to mutate and the amino
acid we want to replace this lets us see
how the modification will affect our
complex on several parameters including
stability and binding
our example looks at the complex formed
by prolactin and its
receptor to input our pdb structure
click on data source in our case we will
be using the pdbid3mzg
our structure is displayed in three
dimensions
the orange color represents the receptor
and the green the prolactin
in the upper tab our sequence is
displayed with both chains in the
receptor sequence we will look for the
position
188. which contains histidine and select
it the letter will be highlighted as
well as the position in the structure
window at the same time in the site
directed mutagenesis window will appear
h1a
underscore what we will do is replace it
with r symbol of the arginine amino acid
and then click run experiment a window
pops up allowing us to select the app
and the scorer that we will use for the
experiment
we will select the log likelihood app in
both
and click on run
as we can see our experiment is launched
and it will take a few hours to process
once our experiment succeeds we can
explore the results
to do so we click on the experiment
within the results we see different
sections
we have options a table and a graph
in the options section we select what
parameters we want in the results table
and in the graph we'll select stability
and binding as our parameters
the results are presented as free
energies for both binding and stability
for a better binding or a higher
stability we're looking for the lowest
value
in the graph we will see that the native
structure represented with the pink dot
has a better binding and a higher
stability as expected
we can also compare result values in the
table
the experiment shows us that by
substituting the histidine and position
188 of the receptor with arginine will
reduce the binding between prolactin and
its receptor what we have done in just a
few clicks replicates what was done
experimentally in a research paper
highlighting how a single mutation on a
prolactin receptor can lead to a disease
called hyperprolactinemia
which causes infertility after seeing
how easy it is to run a site-directed
mutagenesis experiment in silico using
deep chain and the reliable results it
provides just think of all the
possibilities this powerful time and
resource saving tool offers
to learn more sign up now at
deepchain.bio thank you for listening
thank you for your time